there's this guy named Michael Knowles
from the daily wire some of you know him
as the daily wire third Stringer behind
Matt Walsh and Ben Shapiro anyway I've
been on his show before
I stopped going on his show because
nothing positive came from it it doesn't
doesn't have a big enough audience that
it actually did anything for me
but I would get a barrage of
anti-Semitic messages from his viewers
that very same Michael Knowles
thought yesterday to say you know what
David pakman is making up that he's
getting anti-semitic emails and threats
as a result of his tweet here is what
Michael Knowles had to say and of course
there's always this very you know his
background is in acting there's always
this overly dramatic acting that he's
doing he's just so upset so upset by my
tweet there was the most vile reaction
that I've seen to the shooting in
Nashville it was from someone who's
appeared on this show actually he's a
liberal but he's appeared on this show
yeah and it's it's just so hideous yeah
but and I bring it up not even just to
castigate this guy right but but to show
you how wrong the the libs thinking is
in fact our thinking is a thousand
percent right
in that
the thoughts and the prayers do nothing
and the Republicans don't want to do
anything other than that the thinking is
a hundred percent right how pervasive
this kind of vile thinking is but also
how wrong it is sure uh David packman
yeah tweeted Out quote very surprising
that there would be a mass shooting at a
Christian School given that lack of
prayer is often blamed for these
horrible events it's possible they
weren't praying enough or correctly
isn't this just like obvious despite
being a Christian School
yeah they send thoughts and prayers
and there's a shooting at a place where
people are praying obviously the elected
officials
who only send thoughts and prayers
are horrible people unwilling to
actually do anything to solve this
problem what's so complicated about that
that is the most vile tweet I've ever
read
can you imagine has he ever does he
remember when Trump was on Twitter the
most vile tweet so the hyperbole is
going a little far I have to say
and Twitter is a cesspool
for the most vile kinds of speech you
can imagine that's true now that's true
if you have any kind of public profile
at all you've seen you've seen plenty of
vile stuff directed at you yeah
much of it that is much of it from his
audience a single most vile tweet I have
ever read really it must be very
sheltered you ended up deleting it but
he didn't apologize well no I mean
people deliberately misconstrued it to
send a hate mob against me why would I
apologize it's accurate the thoughts and
prayers didn't prevent the shooting and
our elected officials need to do more
and they're unwilling to
in fact he played the victim he said all
right too many anti-semitic attacks and
threats to my family I've delete the
tweet
so be why that's
one no one saw any of these alleged
anti-semitic attacks or what a what a
joker yeah so anyway
um the anti-semitic attacks
check a couple things on this
I don't want to like highlight too many
of these anti-semitic attacks and
threats because it just feels more of
them but now that someone is prominent
as Michael Knowles
is saying suggesting there are no such
things
uh I have to at least say something
about it first of all check out the
comments just look through the comments
I won't even put them up
check out the comments on the video I
did about this uh the video
um wherein I said a million people are
angry at me my tweet pissed off a
million people
um just scroll through the comments half
of the comments are overtly
anti-submitic comments it's like a
Neo-Nazi KKK meeting
in the comments to the point where
YouTube contacted me and said listen
this is like Beyond just reporting
individual comments because it's it's
just it's all anti-semitic YouTube
doesn't know how to handle the comments
on my YouTube channel because they are
so anti-semitic and I don't know what
Michael Knowles would accept as proof
check out my inbox again a thousand of
these and also some sent to family
members whose contact info these people
found I'm just gonna give you three
examples again because I I want to show
you that these are very real but also
not spend all day showing you these one
person wrote to me calling me a filthy
anti-white k word k word for Jew which I
don't know if it's allowed on radio so
I'm not going to say it and says you're
a rat-faced anti-white k word Who
belongs in Israel I've been to Israel
once for 10 days
someday Jews will have their citizenship
stripped and they will be banned from
holding positions in American government
media Academia and law white people are
simply sick of your Jewish degeneracy
and it's time for Jews to pack up and
leave this is one of a thousand okay
Michael Noel says these don't exist
here's reality Michael Knowles lives in
a fantasy world
we have reality and we have fantasy here
Michael knows lives in fantasy this is
the reality one out of a thousand that I
got second one again just just a
sampling
Jewish from someone who goes by groiper
way to mock the murder of Christians
effing k word k word for Jews okay and
third
f u dumb c word often used for women
have fun in Hell Jew boy Christ is King
Holocaust didn't happen by the way
okay I could do a live stream
all day just reading these they come in
faster than they can be read
if you look at Twitter Youtube my email
inbox Facebook and Instagram
Michael null says the the anti-semitic
messages don't exist they come in at a
rate of more than one every few seconds
okay so that's the truth but Michael
Knowles and others want you to think
there are none and by the way I stopped
doing his show
because every time I was on it
I would get anti-semitic emails it just
wasn't worth it because it wasn't
helping me build my audience it was only
generating hate these people are truly
dangerous and they're depraved but after
the break I'm going to tell you the good
of the last 24 hours